stuff is trading off the board so we're
gonna keep a close eye on this one as we
have a special guest in the studio as
Shula Newman from st. Louis Public Radio
is with Maurice well not just from the
st. Louis Public Radio but also the
executive director so she decides what
goes in paper BigDog there so thanks for
joining us Sheila tell us about your
work there at the st. Louis Public Radio
right so st. Louis Public Radio is the
radio station where a member station for
NPR we serve about a half a million
people via radio and our website STL
public radio org and we specialized we
care we carry national programs but what
I do in my role and what my newsroom
does in its role is to cover the region
and this all extends all the way to
Rolla and all the way up to Quincy so we
have reporters that are based in
Belleville Illinois in Jefferson City at
the Capitol and Rolla and basically we
report on local news and this is local
news for sure what's happening here at
the club of the Sinquefield cup what's
the cut what is the Public Radio's
relationship to the club we have a
long-standing partnership with the Chess
Club actually every week we get a an
article from the Chess Club that's about
chess but it's not for the inside world
of chess it's really for people who to
whet their appetite and to see what a
cool thing chess is it can those
articles cover everything from what's
going on at the chess Hall of Fame to
sometimes you know police and and going
into classrooms and talking with kids
about chess so they cover all kinds of
things we published that once a week on
our website and we also recently had an
event with the Chess Club that was
called chess night of course Kay an IG
HT and we had Betsy there was a bughouse
tournament yes and which is a bit here
on screen oh yeah oh there it is yeah
the hill that was our IT guy actually I
don't the saying and the king of the
hill it was a really fun event and we're
looking forward to doing more well it
looks absolutely fabulous to see Jen
there var
there as well it's like it was really
well attended in fact by quite a few
folks in the club and and our Grand
Master's and apparently your staff
showed up as was absolutely beautiful
how is local NPR st. Louis Public Radio
related to National Public Radio like do
you cover the same things basically
other than the national events well kind
of basically how it works sort of like
NPR is the national international
network news network
they have reporters all over the world
and then all throughout the United
States there are what we call member
stations and we pay dues to NPR and in
exchange we get to run their programming
Morning Edition and all things
considered and also we have a
relationship with them where when news
breaks here locally that is of national
interest
our reporters do the reporting for them
so you can imagine during Ferguson we
had a lot going on with all of the other
big issues happening in Missouri right
now we contribute to the network quite
frequently how your your listeners and
your readers on your website responded
to chess at you've seen is it is it
something popular for the non chess
crowd it's I have to admit it's a small
leadership but that chess column is
always consistently popular so they I
think I think that we have done our part
to help increase the presence and the
visibility of the Chess Club in st.
Louis I hope we have well we appreciate
everything that you do to get that out
now do you play chess yourself I do play
chess and it's also because of the
columns that I started playing reading
because I edit them every week and I'm
reading them and I'm like I used to play
chess when I was a kid and I heard about
ladies night and I started coming out
all winter long and I love chess I
really do I'm horrible at it
you're not winning a bunch of games I've
never won a game we've never won again
why are you taking lessons and ladies
banging I want to get a game the other
women are just as good you gotta help
her out you can't have her getting
discouraged about not winning any games
you know you got to match you up against
Allah and we all will find someone
there's a lot of newcomers to ladies
night now by the way that's our woman's
chest classes on Thursday nights in
three different levels beginner
intermediate and advanced and Dwarfs a
Derrick Shani an international master
women's Grand Master is hosting the
advance group so highly recommended and
you you will win a game just come one
more line I think we're a natural Rachel
Leigh little beat down you know get it
nice and soft
he'll be punch-drunk thank you so much
for joining us early and for all the
work that you do
popularizing chess here in st. Louis
thank you for having me I really
appreciate it thank you
[Music]
you